Ron Ron what do you think about when you  think about Christmas well when I think  about Christmas you know I think about  friends and family it's not goodbye the  house with just bags full of liquor oh  there you are  okay just bags full like you're just  liquor of all kind it's just kind of  just bags full of it it comes in every  day non-stop I mean enough liquor to  last them halfway through January and  you don't have to worry about a thing  eggnog eggnog way from number one to  kill them that's my favorite and if we  run out of eggnog number one tequila by  itself is even better you make it out of  breast milk you can make it out anything  anyway I hope you guys have a great  holiday season and interupt have a  chance to win tickets to see Margo and I  perform somewhere in America you pick  anyway I love you to death and I'll see  you around the bend  bye bye